a cheap festival shouldn't be an
oxymoron most people here booked their
glastonbury tickets before the pandemics
struck now many find themselves in a
very different place financially the
first thing we noticed was petrol so our
petrol we thought it was going to be
about 45 it was 65. so that was the
biggest one for us we've got a lot of
friends who come to glastonbury every
year this is our first year but a lot of
them haven't been able to come this year
because they've had to think about the
rest of the year and what money they're
going to have left to spend over whether
it's for themselves or their children
firstly the cost of getting here was a
lot more expensive and we had to kind of
factor that in this is our second
festival on the chart and all the
festivals all the prices have gone up
tickets cost an eye-watering 285 pounds
compare that to back in 1970 when it was
just a pound to get in
if the cough now seems a struggle to
swallow don't forget that food and beer
has also gone up not to mention petrol a
300 mile round trip to glastonbury from
london in 2019 cost 53 pounds but this
year it's shot up by an extra 25 pounds
to 78.
at the left field stage created by billy
bragg the lineup includes a talk on the
cost of living i think people will want
to hear about you know the situation we
find ourselves in and how we address it
you know the the the press about the
current situation is all focused on the
wage price spiral it's not at all
focused on how we do
capitalism how we you know over the last
50 years our such a larger chunk of the
pie has gone to shareholders and bosses
rather than gone to the workforce helen
had been hoping to clean up from a
summer of dishing out meals at festivals
up and down the country because of the
cost that we uh everything has gone up
and things like that as well we're only
doing two and in a normal summer we do
sort of eight or nine we just haven't
been able to make that that capital uh
and
for numerous reasons and because it's so
expensive to do we can't afford the the
the petrol and the running costs and the
the stock costs to be able to do them
this year
so while this paints a picture of a
thriving festival scene sadly the
reality is quite different as ticket
prices soar and festivals around the uk
are forced to cancel so it might be back
to normal here after two years of covert
closures but now a whole new set of
challenges for the music industry
katie spencer sky news in glastonbury